[Music]
what does a jigsaw puzzle championship
look like i was totally surprised
because i always think of it as a
relaxing meditative so it's like
you know a meditation competition or a
napping
uh competition but i found out about it
because i was googling
first of all one of the first facts
about jigsaws is that hugh jackman is a
huge fan huge he spent about 10 minutes
of maybe 15. on
our podcast he and i together talking
about jigsaw puzzles so yes huge jigsaw
puzzle fan but one of the other results
this is right before the pandemic was
that there was a
world championship in spain and it
listed all of the countries that were
competing and there were tons of them
there were 40 countries mexico japan
uganda but no usa so on a whim i fill
out the form and figure that'll be the
first of this long process to qualify i
get back an email the next day you are
team usa and i'm like oh wow that's not
good the next day no due diligence at
all
it was a disaster uh yeah and i as i
said i didn't love jake's i thought they
were i was a snob i thought they were
too easy they were not sophisticated so
i was like oh god so i recruited my
family to be is a four-person team and
we flew to spain and
you have eight hours
to finish four giant jigsaw puzzles and
we were a disa i mean i'm sorry i
apologize to my fellow americans because
we came in second to last we be we beat
one of the spanish hometown teams so
that's something
but these
despite us the humiliation i loved it
because it was just so fascinating for
so many reasons first just being able to
see people at the top of
the lebron james's of jigsaw so know
even if jake saw as you think is a silly
a silly past i'm seeing anyone and you
know this you've interviewed that's sort
of the premise you interview the top
people of every category and you're
gonna learn something from them and
these people their hands move so fast
we
finished one puzzle
of the four in six and a half hours
the russian team these women four women
from siberia finished in
just over four hours the whole thing
they their hands were moving so fast and
there were rumors of doping but i'm not
to not confirm um
and the another part i loved was just
meeting people from all over the world
united by this weird obsession and i
talk about jigsaw diplomacy i actually i
felt i was a little ahead of the curve
because i have a paragraph in the book
about how much i hate putin
this is long before the ukraine before
it was cool yeah
before it was going and i say but i
can't hate these people because i'm here
in face to face and they're humans and
you know i am hoping that they're one of
the some of the millions who oppose what
putin is doing now but
but it was sort of what i call jigsaw
diplomacy
so it was a wonderful experience and
also learning
like in everything there are strategies
you think oh it's just putting together
but and the strategies are sometimes
surprising you don't always everyone's
like oh do the do the edges first no not
necessarily some puzzles if they have
very colorful you do the colors first
sometimes you focus on shapes if you're
hit with the sky like a huge expanse of
blue you've got to sort them by shapes
so this one has two audis and one innie
this one so it was just wonderful to see
the nuances
of
this
delightful and ridiculous competition
and yeah it was one of my favorite
experiences i have a number of questions
about this the first is
how do you
delegate
or divide and conquer as a team because
i can imagine if four people were just
let loose having no strategy trying to
put together a jigsaw puzzle it might
take longer than just one person trying
to do it if you don't have some type of
plan going into it and second i'm just
curious did you notice any sponsors i'm
just wondering what kind of
financial support is offered to the
world jigsaw
puzzle championships
i'm guessing it's not you know bmw maybe
not yet but i mean this was right before
the covet when jigsaws experienced a
boom during coven that's true not seen
since the great depression so they
became harder to get than clorox wipes
so so maybe now
they could be sponsored by vmware but
then yes it was
the only sponsor was the puzzle company
itself ravensburger sadly so i didn't
make a huge amount of money on it as the
second to last finisher
yeah i feel it's something oh it's it's
you finished you finished no it's a
thing i need someone so for strategies
like yeah what do you do as a team well
you're absolutely right that was the
secret that the russians had they told
me it's all about division of labor like
in many endeavors so there was one woman
who specialized in sorting colors and
another assorted shapes another sorted
what was good at the edges and another
was really good at
the trial and error because you i often
um you know i'm afraid to put something
down if i don't think she was like no
just do it just be okay with failing you
know she put things she'd try it no next
one no next one yes
so
yeah it was fascinating to see the
division and i found that as a theme
throughout puzzle solving i went to this
one event that was sort of the iron man
triathlon for nerds which was called a
puzzle hunt and it was at mit 2000
people like rock real rocket scientists
and they come together for 72 hours and
solve the hardest
craziest most baffling nonsensical
puzzles that involve like
advanced calculus and justin bieber's
tour schedule and just the most random
things you can think of and you need 50
people on a team the teams are 50 people
because you needed specialists
in
all these areas so yes
sort of a diversification and having
different people do different things is
a big theme i think in in puzzles and
life
you